i have some big news for you starting in
september i am debuting my own talk show
i have always wanted to do a talk show
even before i joined the view in 2007 i
wanted this job bad i'm telling you i
called barbara every day about four
years ago i started telling god i said
lord i want a talk show
and when god says it's so it will be so
thank you
sherry fought back tears this morning
announcing she's taking over wendy's
show the 54 year old will be filling in
once a month until summer break her new
show debuts in the fall as for wendy's
reaction i am
going back stronger well just last week
she was strolling on a florida beach
vowing to return after being away for
seven months to deal with medical issues
i want to be all i can be
and then get back to new york and get on
down the wendy williams show
after that infamous fainting on air in
2017 in her battle with addiction and
graves disease wendy's comeback is on
hold for now today wendy's rep told us
it's been a challenging time for wendy
and quote she more than anyone
understands the reality of syndicated
television you can't go to the
marketplace and sell a show that's the
maybe windy show some fans suggest wendy
should return with her own podcast as
for sherry she had nothing but love no
one can replace the queen
nobody
wendy williams created a unique brand
that folks are always gonna love and
talk about
but i am so excited for you to go on
this sherry show journey with me this
september
[Music]